il n'aura fallu que 24 heures pour que
la ministre de la famille se penche sur
le dossier
ça a été excessivement troublant force
est d'admettre sans équivoque qu un
crime sexuel commis sur une pile de
quatre ans dans une garderie
subventionnée par son gouvernement n'a
pas reçu l'attention méritée
on a demandé aux bureaux coordonnateurs
de revoir sa décision
et pendant ce temps où ils vont revoir
cette décision suspendre les
responsables des services de garde pour
s'assurer que la réflexion se fait avec
énormément d'attention
la ministre de la famille veut savoir
pourquoi le permis de7 garderie n'a pas
été remis en question alors que la
responsable des services de garde a
clairement été négligents et je vous le
dis ce qui m'inquiète encore plus c'est
un cas comme celui lors fait en sorte
qu'on peut porter un jugement négatif
sur les 91 mille places qu'on a un
service de garde en milieu familial en
ce moment on a des gens d'exception qui
donne des services et c'est justement
pour protéger l'intégrité du système que
le gouvernement a décidé sur le champ de
réviser les règles qui encadrent tous
les services de garde offert aux enfants
sans exception
le système telle qu'elle est déficient
ils sont je crois s'attarder à chacune
de ces règles pour s'assurer que qu'il
soit où qu'il soit cet enfant là ils
soient en sécurité
la ministre confirme ainsi que pour la
première fois le gouvernement songe à
encadrer les garderies familiales non
subventionnées qui poussent comme des
champignons pour répondre à la demande
mais qui pour le moment sont exploitées
sans permis sans inspection pourtant
elle représente 50 mille places au
québec un non sens explique cette jeune
maman de la région de québec
y a pas de critères comme tels ou
d'encadrement
quand elle s'est présentée à sa garderie
dans la région de québec il y a trois
semaines avec son poupon la dpj étaient
sur place pour l'informer qu'un
pédophile reconnu le conjoint la
gardienne côtoyaient les enfants depuis
deux ans on apprend et on sent coupable
ça fait aucun sens ce qui nous est
arrivé
je veux que tous les parents sachent que
lorsqu'ils font porter leur enfant dans
un milieu dans un service de garde en
milieu familial qui est privé que
personne que vérifier tout ce qu elle
aussi a choisi de se battre comme
jennyfer brunswick la mer
de la fillette de 4 ans pour un système
plus vigilants maintenant je suis
contente avec finalement une réponse
elle attend maintenant les changements
tamara la ministre a beau vouloir
resserrer toutes les règles attention
est sans doute très bonne mais est ce
que c'est vraiment possible dans un
système qui est aussi complexe que non
probablement mais c'est tout un contrat
de le faire
comme je vous disais l'offre au québec
est tellement compliquée demandez à
n'importe quel parent qui affronte le
système jeudi affronte parce que c'est
vraiment une épreuve c'est difficile
entre le cpe la garderie familiale
subventionner les garderies familiales
non subventionnées la garderie privée
réglementés et non réglementée
c'est difficile de faire un choix
éclairé car ces établissements sont pas
tous soumis aux mêmes règles et des fois
y'a pas de choix à faire on prend ce qui
passe faute de place donc si les temps
sont aujourd'hui du gouvernement c'est
d'imposer les mêmes règles la même
médecine à tous ces établissements
c'est une chose mais ça peut pas se
faire sans des sommes sans doute une
financement additionnel c'est beau
changer les règles mais faut s'assurer
qu'elles soient respectées mais ça prend
des ressources et ça il ya la
communication du tout aujourd'hui non
j'ai parlé après le point de presse de
la ministre à son cabinet qui me disait
qu'on y por rendu là ce qu'on dit en
fait ce qui est clair aujourd'hui c'est
qu'un ministre était consciente des
craintes des parents des doutes qui sont
soulevées chez les parents et l'idée
aujourd'hui c'était de les rassurer
maintenant jusqu'où est ce que le
gouvernement est prêt à aller quand il
dit qu ils vont resserrer les règles
elle disait plutôt la ministre hier on
s'est assis ensemble on s'est regardés
dans le blanc des yeux camps se
regardent dans le blanc des yeux parce
qu'on se dit les cas méritait donc forcé
d'admettre qu'ils ont un problème d'une
déficience dans le système encore une
fois jusqu où est ce que le gouvernement
est prêt à aller pour assurer que ce
système soit désormais sans faille ça la
ministre n'a pas été clair à ce sujet
est encore trop tôt
30 ou merci beaucoup tamara je m'en a
pris